there are few Signs of Life bubbling
under the technology is expensive
electricity is needed Round the Clock to
maintain oxygen levels the tank is
actively monitored for temperature and
nutrition
Rakesh Menon started shrimp farming last
year he says this modern method is more
profitable in the natural pond where you
where you're doing the low density here
we are doing it in the high density at
the same time uh in a year we are doing
like four culture in a year if you
compare it with the natural one they are
doing it twice in a year so that is more
different than where you can do more
culture at the same time where you can
earn more profitable than this
shrimp cultivation is big business in
the southern Indian state of Kerala the
government is promoting it by
subsidizing land and giving technical
support to Farmers but mangroves are
being cleared to make way for them
kerala's Forest cover has reached a
historic low in some areas there are
motion Farms than mangroves most of what
remains is privately owned and
unprotected mangroves have been globally
recognized as one of the best ways to
counter climate change they absorb more
carbon than other tropical forests and
also protect coastlines from natural
disasters such as tsunamis scientists
say that depletion is threatening
ecosystems and local economies
Arun Kumar has been fishing in this
River for decades he says the growing
number of shrimp Farms has affected his
business there are few fish to catch and
some species have gone extinct
farmers use chemicals to kill all the
organisms in the water this is done
before they put the shrimp seeds this
water then flows into the river this is
killing the fish there was one fish
called kurupa it's not there anymore
conservationists want the state
government to step up Mangrove
protection they say these can coexist
with shrimp Farms we have to do
sustainable shrimp farming and we have
traditional method of shrimp farming
prevalent in Kerala and now the the
non-traditional more intensive shrimp
farming is is changing the geomorphology
of the of the area and the and even the
restoration becomes difficult in these
landscapes
men inside shrimp grown this way is
better and other farmers will switch to
this method but conservation is sworn
unchecked farming could wipe away
critical Forest cover and endanger
thousands of
liveseri Southern India